hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of
collider connected i am beyond thrilled
to be doing a south by south
west edition of the show right now and
especially because it means i get to
talk to lucy lawless for the spine of
night of all movies
lucy i'm freaking out about that movie
are you really
it's so good it's so bloody i just
like i can't remember the last time i've
seen something like that
yeah pretty crazy um psychedelic vision
for
from phil gelatin and the team but i
think it started
with him right and uh and ended with him
and it's a real labor of love
but um i was drawn to it immediately
because
in my childhood there was this crazy
cartoon called clutch chicago which was
very two-dimensional and then they would
have real mouths sort of rotoscoped in
doing the talking
and um i thought it was really boring
but quite
mesmerizing and um anyway when i saw it
i was like oh my god this
is like the 70s all over again you know
like somebody spoke to big old doobie
when they came up with that or something
psychedelic about it you know pretty
nutty stuff
and i just thought yeah i want to be
part of this
i've never seen that show you brought up
and i don't know if i'm picturing the
right thing but have you ever gone on i
guess
like tick tock and snapchat and seen
those filters where you can turn
yourself into a potato and stuff and all
you see is your real life
moving with uh with an animated potato i
confess i've never been on tick tock
um it's a journey all right so i warned
you we are going back to the very
beginning and
by the very beginning i mean step one do
you remember the
very first thing that made you say i
want to be an actor
whether it was a movie you loved a
personal experience
seeing an idol do it something along
those lines um
i remember i i don't know how old i was
quite young
six seven eight something my sitting in
the tv room with my brother's older
brothers and a girl came on
the tv doing an ad with a kiwi accent
and they were like she gets paid heaps
for doing that
and i went oh my god that's a job like
i'm seven i could do that you know
that's when i realized oh my goodness
that's an option
for a girl with an accent like me um
so people need to see themselves
represented on on
tv for all sorts of reasons but uh and
that's why
um we're seeing what we have to do with
diversity and
and people need to see themselves
absolutely
so when you get that idea in your head
and you picture yourself at the very
beginning
making it so to speak what exactly did
you picture at that point was it making
it on broadway doing comedy being an
action star maybe
being interviewed by some at that time
um british
interviewers um i thought that would be
part of it
um they're all dead and gone now so you
see yourself at the oscars and you see
i remember one time b goldberg said in
her speech
if for all the kids out there who want
to be up here someday you better believe
it kid
and that was like a turning point for me
like yeah you gotta believe it you gotta
back yourself
and um so she unwittingly was very
instrumental in in my
uh career i love hearing that so
you commit to you know uh pursuing the
dream
what would you say was the first i guess
kind of high
value step that you talk that you took
towards making that dream a reality
something that made you think it's not
just a pipe dream it's something that
i'm actually doing right now
well i ran off to vancouver to study
acting and that was really good
you know taking all kinds of training
whether it's voice or whatever you can
do that in your hometown you can find
somebody to
to creatively spark off uh people who
help you with technique and all that
stuff i think that's the first thing
that
everybody should be doing if you have a
creative bone in your body
nourish it you know feed it and um so
that would be the first thing and then
having the
balls to get up and go to canada um even
though i was
i actually was a teenager when i got
pregnant
and thereafter married so that a lot of
people thought oh well there goes lucy's
big dreams and but i didn't see it that
way
i chose to be oblivious to all those
kind of naysayers and just
press on to and do what you dream and in
those days it was really hard like to
get yourself to drama school was
a big to-do you had to go to the
consulate and get a phone book for
england or
canada or whatever and look up their
names and then you had to write to them
that would take two weeks for the letter
to get there and maybe they'd respond
it'd take two weeks to get back so you
know it's a very long process you
couldn't
just access info and contacts on um
online so you had to be
really committed and keep busy in the
times when you
didn't have work or when there was no
validation
that word didn't even exist in those
days that was something to do with your
parking ticket
but um you just had to yeah you have to
feed your creativity when nobody else is
were you focusing on anything specific
in drama school
like a a particular type of performance
theater
shakespeare shakespeare hitta gobbler
you know the um the classics
that i never foresaw where the hell my
career would go
i i was terrible at sports
i have zero interest in
fantasy and barely even sci-fi
um so none of all of this is a
complete shock to me even looking back i
go how did that happen that was crazy
and then when you get an on-screen gig i
know the first one was the sketch comedy
show
so jumping into that first is there
anything about
that being your first on-screen
experience that you think
benefited you versus having a more
traditional show
being the first thing on your resume oh
yeah because
comedy um you have to fly by the seat of
your pants you know you
so and it was just a bunch of kids
having fun i didn't
so i was freer you know the minute you
care too much you clam up in comedy and
then you just can't do it it doesn't
work
so um i always enjoyed the comic
episodes of things that i've done
because
um they're just so much makes sense but
so much more fun on set
i don't know how you make comedy in a in
an
arena of tension but i guess some people
do it
over the course of your career when you
did hit points where
you were kind of fielding a certain kind
of validation or having your work
critiqued how how do you go about
keeping that uh
i guess that spontaneity and that fun
vibe about approaching your material and
not feeling weighted down by that kind
of
assessment i remain completely
disconnected from it
i don't listen to it i don't admit it in
my house
um you know my husband was being a
producer was always
interested in reviews and numbers and
what people are saying online and i
eventually had to say just
don't don't don't tell me that stuff i'm
not
don't bring it in here because it's um
it's immaterial for one thing and it's
really negative
that's very very fair all right taken a
step
forward now to hercules and the amazon
women
when you first joined the cast of that
what were your expectations for your
involvement and i i guess when you first
signed on for that did you have any idea
that it was going to serve as a pilot
for a series
oh i tell you what i did the audition i
got the job
um they were looking at me for the role
of the amazon
queen hippolyta which eventually went to
rome downey they just decided i was too
young
i think i was 24. so they gave me her
lieutenant i was so nervous
the night before that i was just pacing
and i couldn't settle i was i was having
circular thoughts i was freaked out
because i'd never done a role so big
and my husband at the time one of the
best things he ever said to me was
just lie the [ __ ] down and go to sleep
and i went
like somebody took the power like out of
my hands for a minute because i was just
in a terrible state about the
responsibility of it all
and it was great so
then over the course of uh of your run
on that and leading up to leading your
own show with xena
do you think that that experience
prepared you enough for that or did you
have one of those sleepless nights
before stepping onto the set of a show
that you are headlining
no the other one was much more
nerve-wracking it was a three-episode
arc i'd never done anything so big
and but um doing the show just felt like
a normal day at the office actually
pretty great
and then meeting renee was interesting
you know because she was
really like the character she was so
like
overwatch to meet me which is ridiculous
because i'm just
a couple of years older and had done
nothing right but she was like her
character
or bouncy like puppy and um
but she became one of my great friends
in all the world
backtracking a little because it is so
unusual that we see
one actor play multiple roles on
not just a single show but a collection
of them so
was it just a shock every single time
they came up with a new idea for you
well you know the pool of actors who
could do an american accent i guess was
quite small and if you
always hear acts going it's hercules and
we still laughed at this diva hercules
because it so diminishes the um
hero to be called hercules
to an american ear and um no it was
it was great it was all good
so going off of xena now
you have been a pretty hugely
influential queer rights icon for years
and years so
do you remember what it was like when
fans first started embracing
that quality of the character and also
you
coming to the decision that it wasn't
just something that you wanted to sit
back and
watch people uh embrace but you wanted
to embrace it and support it as
actively as you do yourself yeah i do
remember the exact moment when it came
to our attention renee and i on the
side of set reading this big long scroll
because faxes came out in scrolls in
those days
information from the village voice
writing this article about was michael
musto writing about how
xeno and gabrielle were queer characters
and we're like what the hell
we will go that's crazy and we're like
that's cool um
the decision to support um the gay
community
the fact that they should be judged
unequal for
um you know writ large is
disgraceful and unacceptable good good
souls and i'm sick of um
i hate that kind of injustice against
children
people are queer or
straight or whatever they are from
before the time they're born
so to be adjudicating them is less than
from they're getting those messages
implicitly or explicitly from such an
early age it's a
terrible it's it's a violence to me
it's violence against children and um
that just goes throughout their lives so
we want to eradicate that stop being
violent to children
and telling them that they don't belong
it's it stops him i love that you do
that and it's also taking a similar
approach to
uh your social media as well and the
reach that you have there
so i guess what what advice would you
give to someone else in the industry
maybe a newcomer first gaining that kind
of fan base who
might be hesitant or scared to use their
voice on
social media or elsewhere to speak out
about the causes that are important to
them
yeah it's really important to well you
have to identify what are your causes
and you have to keep it a little bit
your lines a little bit clean you can't
be like going out off about everything
because people just stop listening you
know
but so make sure it's weighted where you
want it to be weighted
and also it's really important to
descend if you're feeling it
because the more we get this sort of
conspiracy of silence like oh be quiet
don't make waves
um the more impoverished democracy is
so having the right to say this is
absolutely unacceptable i don't tolerate
it
is the only bulwark we have against
extremism and malaise and being
um what did non-chomsky call it um
manufactured consent
you know don't be manufactured don't
have your consent taken you have to
speak your truth and stand by it and you
know you get trolls online guess what
hey don't read them or b you have to
know how to handle that because it it
only hurts the first two times and after
that it's like
oh
when they say something richard i go yes
and i invite you to punish me by
pressing
unfollow like i don't
give a [ __ ] about your objection to me
but that's me well it might be me now
because i feel like i'm going to take
what you just said and i'm going to put
in my back pocket for when i have to
deal with situations like that
yeah but it means nothing you know
you have for example in the old days
it'll be something hideous written about
you in print
could be false could be true something
that is written about you in print but
something
unkind and guess what it's on the bottom
of the woman budgie cage the next day
well these days it's online which is you
know its own
thing but um still focus when you bring
yourself into the now and go well i'm in
this nice room
i have you know nice children or
whatever you know focus on what you do
have and stop making that thing real
like you can create a very false reality
you can choose to opt in or opt out
life's better when you opt out very very
true
win for short times and then opt out for
the rest and go back to your real life
read a book sounds like a good plan to
me
in the worst transition ever here going
back to your screen work
i know the industry often likes to box
folks in
when they do something and they do it
really well so what was it like
after xena came to a close did you find
that you were getting
similar roles and was it difficult to
break out of that box or maybe did you
even want to embrace it
i think i realized quite early on i
don't have any choice but to embrace it
because
my age she was good to me and the
character i mean xena the show gave me
everything i
my family um my friends
um yes i i didn't think i would be boxed
in but i was back baptized in a peculiar
way
where people think that oh she's from
that 90s show
it was cheesy i didn't really watch it i
kind of it was cheesy
she's cheese now i happen to like cheese
i think it's one of the best things on
earth
um so yes i did get boxed in i kind of
didn't realize it at the time it's only
in retrospect but i seem to have just
climbed out you know you just just
endure just endure keep
walking through new doors keep doing
things that scare you
um because by golly if you live to be 80
um you're going to look back on all this
and go wow none of that mattered
but boy did i have a good time so be
brave
with that in mind with all of the
projects you've done over the years is
there any particular one that you would
say scared you the most
um probably lucretia was pretty damn
scary
xena was scary on that physical level
because it was just relentless
and i hated the action i just hate
fighting but
again i didn't have an option to hate it
so i didn't indulge that
but spartacus was very difficult for you
know that whole nudity thing is quite um
counter to one's nature and to our to
our culture
and um i was just watching god's at the
arena the other night somebody
and my husband had it on because we've
been through everything else you know on
online
everything you can stream we've seen and
uh so we went back and watched our old
show
and um my goodness that was a really
hardcore very rich storytelling
um so that was probably the scariest and
the best wrong this is a very random one
but i was just thinking about this the
other day because i was re-watching
these movies
i'm very curious how your spider-man
cameo came to be
like whose idea was that well sam raimi
was
one of the executive producers on um
xena and hercules and is one of rob's
oldest friends so
he just invited me i was in new york and
um i just rocked up and
and then i wore that punk outfit home on
the plane
and um yeah people aren't that nice to
pugs
they're frightened and they act in a way
that's a little bit hostile
whose idea was that particular line
then that's pure sam did you did you
shoot anything beyond that just to kind
of play around with it
no that's really it you made you made
your impression with it though so job
well done
yeah yeah okay with uh
with tv in general
you've also guested on a slew of
shows over the years and there's no way
i can cover every single one
right now so is there anyone in
particular that made an especially big
impression on you that you look back on
fondly maybe you'd want to return to
that character if you had the
opportunity
the sort of the big three in my mind
would be
um curb your enthusiasm
your enthusiasm simpsons and of course
parks and rec those were
those were the big three for me
solid solid choice there although i am a
little sad you didn't name drop ruby
from ash versus evil dead
oh my god ruby that was the worst
character ever it's like what the hell
was she
we're all like when bruce would go who
is ruby
we were like we don't know they haven't
bloody written it yet
so um i mean i had a lot of fun hanging
out with those
those actors i love the show it's just
in terms of a role like i don't know
what that was
that's the benefit of doing uh sci-fi
fantasy though you could
you could swing big and make it work it
felt right to me
oh good i'm really glad just because i'm
curious
do you have any idea what was planned
for season four it really did feel like
at the end when that was canceled it was
almost like the rug being pulled out
from under fans because there was such a
good cliffhanger
i'm um i'm sure that was the rug being
pulled out from under um
uh i don't know actually i don't know i
don't remember what the truth of that
was but
i know rob would have wanted it to go
another year or so
yeah i guess there's there's no chance
you'll jump into evil dead rise is there
um i i doubt it and i've got all my own
stuff going on too but um
no that'll be one of those um kids in
the woods
pack of things i don't know
i'm feeling very good about that one
jumping into
the spine of night now i guess i guess
the first thing i'm most curious
about is what was the pitch like for the
movie
to you were they able to paint a clear
enough picture for what they were
striving for
just by i guess explaining it no
i saw um i saw a rough
cut of it and i just went this is
bonkers and this reminds me of 1972
you know movies from that uh cartoons
from that europe maybe we didn't have it
to be in 1972 it probably
did black and white so it would have
been a little bit later than that but
certainly um the movies that it reminds
me of are from
late 60s early 70s they're already old
by the time i was
cognizant of them um what was the pitch
legs like do you wanna do you wanna do
this you know
uh a little bit of flattery was in there
which
water off a duck's back but um i just
thought it was
uh cool and bizarre and kind of ugly
beautiful
and my lawyer said lucy do you really
want to be seen that way and i went
yeah because this is sort of a lump of a
woman she's a shamanist and she's
she walks that you know like a caveman
as she's australopithecus walken
and um and she's cool
she's awesome she's magic and she's ugly
beautiful
she is super cool and she she stands for
some very good things i
quite liked the character with the
physicality in mind is there
anything you could do to tap into that
when you're actually doing your voice
work or is that not even necessary
no that is a big part of it actually to
because your voice
has to make the sounds of the movement
so you physically have to
um in some way
uh replicate that you know what you're
seeing that's really important
for getting the rhythm right um
xena taught me to like i'm a killer
looper
my adr is like because we would have to
do so much to so late at night you just
get
really good i've done thousands of hours
of looping and um
uh yeah anyway i enjoyed that part of it
to create that character but
and and also um
because phil was working at this on his
own you're locked into the picture
so the rhythm of the person speaking
who initially did it is the rhythm that
you have to go but it's not necessarily
what you would have done
um you know most animation they do the
voice first
and then they animate two picture but
this is the other way around so
um that also gives it a
slightly uh a mannerism
the whole thing has it has a um um
a rhythm that is
it just it's kind of lean and bizarro
and that's why part of the reason why
do you have a preference one way or the
other because i i
imagine both ways of recording whether
it's uh before or after the animation is
complete or semi-complete has its pros
and cons so if you had to choose one way
to work on an animated film what would
it be
i think this is really unique this is
because it's
you know a couple of filmmakers working
four years
in their own uh garage i say that
metaphorically
[Music]
this is not the way that anybody does it
but i think it makes it
really i don't know everything old is
new again
and there's something lean in about it
it's just kind of
bonkers nobody would choose to do it
this way but
i think it's cool that they did is there
anything about doing it this way
that you think is going to serve your
future
voice work well like a new skill that
you might have picked up that you can
bring to whatever you're going to record
next
um well everything strengthens you you
know everything strengthens your
your techniques and and your makes you
more flexible
i don't know i'm proud of it i think
it's really
kind of charming in some grotesque way
i can't i can't exactly explain why i
would call it charming but i think
you're spot on with that
yeah it definitely has that quality to
it
yeah it's nutty so i was um
i was reading phillips uh director's
statement on this
and i love how he explains why he's uh
drawn to the fantasy
genre so as someone who has had much
experience in that genre yourself
i guess what is it about fantasy that
keeps you coming back for more
oh no fantasy chose me i don't i
i always look for the um the
mundane you know the banality of evil is
what makes evil kind of
interesting and um quirky you can embed
truth within the fantasy you can tell
it's like battlestar galactica had a lot
of uh
socio-political commentary to make in a
way that
is it's just sort of embedded in the
narrative so people can discuss
deeper meanings afterwards it gives you
lots to think about
this the story they're telling is not
the story underneath at all you know
absolutely another thing that his
director's statement got me thinking
about
and also i think something that applies
to you having worked on an animated film
in a more independent setting like this
and also having done the big studio fair
is there anything about spine of night
that you think the folks at the studio
should
should take note of to influence either
their process
or the content they're producing as far
as
i guess just encouraging studios to take
more storytelling risks that we don't
see as often that we're getting here
yeah because it's it's so unconventional
the way that
well the story first of all the way that
they went about it everything is i love
that they're taking a punt on somebody
who is
outside the box well outside the box who
was settling
satellite
[Laughter]
um i love that i've got to give them
credit
for feeling it because
um it's very hard to define what makes
this project
super hockey you know it hooks you a
little bit
um but bless them for getting on board
that is not the passion i love the
passion of this guy
right and the single-mindedness that
like
the drive that's the um he just
he kept nourishing that creative spirit
until he bloody
produced a finished film it's
unbelievable the odds against that
are infinitesimal it's definitely one of
those projects where you can
feel the passion for the material and
just the animation format in general
leaping off the screen and i
i think that has great value in addition
to just the story
being told here and look who came on
board patton
oswalt you know richard e grant john a
bunch of other cool people it's like
that's really wow i was really delighted
to be find myself amongst them
i assume you didn't get the opportunity
to work with any of the uh
other voice actors on this right you're
just you're solo
no i'm in new zealand and we do between
lockdowns and
um i'm sure they're also locked down
where they are
so it's fun to be able to to be taken
somewhere else isn't it that's what
we're all enjoying in this
not a friendly world out there for us at
the moment you know the news is all
about to be taken somewhere else into
fantasy realms is such a
psychic relief one of the
the greatest things of the past year is
all the uh the television and movies
that we've been able to see because
honestly i
i don't know what i would have done
without this
i agree i mean god bless all you people
for making such
such wonderful wonderful fear for us
it's been
incredible and we're seeing catching up
on all the things we didn't get to see
right
and appreciating people's work
absolutely
that could bring us to the end of
collider connected we're going to do
some some very random questions and
because of what you just said i'll go
with what is the most recent show that
you binge watched
prior to gods of the arena um lupin
and prior to that queen's gambit yeah ah
queen's game are
you a chess player by chance no
no i'm not it didn't spark any interest
to uh to dig into it more
a little bit actually but did i follow
up no
i think i have the same problem if
you could cast yourself in any other
movie
that's come out already what would you
choose and which character would you
play
oh i'd wanna you'd wanna be ripley you
wanna
you wanna be sigourney weaver she's the
koi the high priestess of it all
i don't think you're gonna see
she's she's amazing i'm glad she did it
that was so inspirational
absolutely i love that choice
did you pick up any new hobbies
during lockdown i did go through the
sourdough bread phase
um i've been through the making cheese
phase i just got busy thinking about my
own projects and i want to
make a documentary next i want to direct
a documentary
um so i'm delving into that subject
matter and um
you have to look for funding but it's
about you keep evolving
keep doing things that that excite you
and and
don't say i could i should be up for the
oscars i should be at the virtual
reality
oscars it's like no just keep moving
wherever you are
is there any particular reason you're
drawn to the the documentary format is
there a particular
topic or cause you really want to cover
uh there's a particular person that i
want to cover for
um a new zealand woman um i want to give
that to the world because
there is an unconventional person who
did some
really wild things and and and my
question is can you outrun your humanity
so um uh anyway more to come on that
is there any proper costume you've kept
from any of your
projects that is especially precious to
you
well the xena one would be the most
precious but i did send it off to the
smithsonian because
um you know they collect all that kind
of stuff and i thought it would just
mulder away in my garage and it would
have but i kind of wish i had it back
now
i don't blame you i bet you still have a
lot of other cool stuff around too
oh my house is so full of swords and
things right am i
used to have one in the trunk of my car
for years because there would be
practice you know you have to practice
with your sword so
my kids have grown up with all kinds of
weapons just lying around the house and
um
not even not particularly interested in
them they're just you know
just household junk to them
what are they thinking that's the
coolest thing ever i know man it's just
normal
you know well i have to let you go
you've got lots to do because you've got
lots to celebrate with the spine of
night so
lucy thank you for hanging out with us
oh my gosh thank you congratulations
because
again i can't emphasize this enough for
anybody out there who wants to see
something that
there's really not a lot of things out
there like please
whatever you have to do do not forget
about the spine of night it's premiering
at south by
keep an eye out for it thank you again
for your time today
pleasure is mine